ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد مع تواصل
الاحتجاجات والضغط على السلطات في مختلف
المدن الايرانيه قالت وسائل اعلام حكوميه
ان الزعيم الايراني علي خمينا ايه دعا الى
اعاده بناء النظام الثقفي في البلاد
وقلاقا من ايه خلال اجتماعهم مع مجلسا
ثقافيه تابع للدوله انهم من الضروري
احداثوا ثوره في البنيه الثقافيه وعلى
المجلس الاعلى مراعاه ضعف الثقافه في مجله
مختلفه في البلاد تصريحاته خامنئي هذه
تاتي بعد ايام من قرار حل جهاز الشرطه
الاخلاق التي طلتها التهامات عديده بعد
وفاه الشباب مساء امين نتيجه تعرضها
للتعذيب من جهتها وكرد فعل على ما يحدث
ندد شقيقه خمنائي بدري حسين حملته القمعيه
على المحتاجين في انحاء البلاد ودعت الحرس
الثوريه للقاء السلاح بحسب ما ورد في
رساله نصرها ابنها المقيم في فرنسا
هناك هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من بيروت
الكاتب الصحفي حسن فحص اهلا بك معنا سيد
حسن الى هذه النشره الى هذا الملف من نقاش
بانوراما طبعا هل يمكن فعلا طرح فكره
اصلاح ثقافي في ايران الفكره في حد ذاتها
ممكن تطبيقها
اعتقد لا من الصعوبه نتحدث عن اصلاح ثقافي
او تعديل ثقافي في اي مجتمع من المجتمعات
وخاصه في المجتمعات
المغلقه او التي تسيطر يسيطر فيها اي نظام
سياسي على الفعل الثقافي لذلك اعتقد ان
الدعوه التي واجهها المرشد الاعلى
والتقدير امام المجلس الاعلى للثوره
الثقافيه هو اعاده النظر
الاليات التي كانت متبعه في السابق والتي
ادت الى هذه النتيجه بان لا يكون النظام
والثوره والمفاهيم الايديولوجيه والفكريه
العقائديه للنظام تاثير على الاجيال
الجديده لذلك
المرشد يحاول انه ان يستعيد المبادره
باعاده انتاج ثقافه تساعده على همم الفرد
او اعاده يعني انتاج القاعده الشعبيه
للثقافيه للنظام ولل الايديولوجيا النظام
الرسميه بما يتوافق مع رؤيته ربما خلينا
نسال في هذا الاطار ضيفنا كذلك يستحق بنا
من الرياضه البحث في شان الايرانيه صالح
حميد صالح اهلا بك معنا لماذا يتحدث
المرشد الايراني في هذا التوقيت بعد فتره
من الاحتجاجات وبعد انتقادات كذلك طالت
النظام بخصوص عدم قدته على وقف هذه
الاحتجاجات وبعد كل ما تبعناه من تطورات
وصولا في اخر هذه التطورات الى تعطيل
دوريات الارشاد او دوريات الاخلاق وشرطه
الاخلاق لماذا يتحدث الان عن منهج الجديد
محاوله اصلاح جديده ستطلق الثقافه
نعم تحياتي لك يا استاذ ريما لطيفه استاذ
حسن الحقيقه ااا يعني اعتقد ان التصريحات
فهمت خطا هو المرشد الايراني دعى الى
اعاده هيكله ما اسمها الثوره الثقافيه
وجاء ذلك في لقائه مع اعضاء المجلس الاعلى
للثوره الثقافيه في ايران اذا ما نريد ان
نفهم تصريحات المرشده يجب ان نعود قليلا
الى الوراء عندما تم تاسيس المجلس الاعلى
للثوره الثقافيه في الثمانينات في عام 81
من قبل المرشد همم انا ذاك الخميني وهو
كان بسبب همم يعني الصراع بين وزاره
التعليم وبين اللجان الثقافيه التي ارادت
ان تؤجلجات كما نعلم يعني كانت هناك
توجهات متشددا الخميني عندما تستلم السلطه
واراد حتى الغاء لولا همم ضغوط همم يعني
الاساتذه والنخبه والحركه الطلابيه القويه
فانشا المجلس الاعلى للثوره الثقافيه من
اجل تعديل المناهج من اجل ما سماها
بتنقيتها من الثقافه الغربيه
وادلجتها بما يتوافق مع النظام
الايديولوجي الديني الجديد همم الان يريد
العوده الى تلك المرحله في الثمانينات
التي الغيت فيها همم يعني معظم العلوم
الانسانيه من فروع الفنون والموسيقى
والى ذلك لانه الان يرى ان الخطر في
الجامعات لانه هناك حضور كبير للحركه
الطلابيه هناك اضرابات ومظاهرات واحتجاجات
واعتصامات متواصله في الجامعات والطلاب
دور مهم في هذا الحراك التي يتحول الى
ثوره شبيهه الثوره التي اطاحت بالشاه يعني
نحن لا نتحدث عن اجراءات اصلاحيه نحن
كاننا نتحدث عن اجراءات الرجعيه همم وهنا
السؤال سيد حسن الى اي مدى هذا الطرح هذه
الفكره قادره ان تتحقق بعد احتجاجات تطالب
بتغيير الواقع بينما خامنئي يتحدث عن
العوده للوراء
الازمه التي يمر بها النظام في التعامل مع
الثقافه
الحراك للشباب همم هو ما قال ما جاء على
لسان القائد السابق ل- همم البسيج همم
محمد همم
الذي يتولى الان مسؤوليه التنسيق في في
مؤسسه الحرس الثوره عندما قال ان همم
الثوره او النظام خسر هذا الجيل وعليه ال-
همم العمل لتاسيس او لتربيه الجيل الجديد
همم في هذا السياق يفهم كلام ايه لانه
يحاول العوده الى اليات قديمه همم
قد تكون مختلفه عامه عامه تبعت همم في
المراحل السابعه والعقول الماضيه لاعاده
انتاج هذا الرجيم
انا انا جيل الاحتجاجات هو جيل متعلم جيل
مثقف لا يخدم النظام
همم ليس فقط هذه المساله لكن
الاليات الثقافيه او التعليميه التي اتبعت
همم
وتداخل قبضه الثقافيه للنظام داخل
الجامعات وداخل الطبقات المثقفه همم نتيجه
المراحل التي مرت بها والتي تحمل
المسؤولياتها للفتره الاصلاحيه يعني
تحديدا همم يجب يجب الخروج منها او او
ترميم او اعاده انتاج ثقافه تخدم المصالح
النظام ورؤيته واهدافه في بناء المجتمع
همم
ثقافيه من قبل السلطه ويخدم همم ويكون
حامل لمشروعها في اداره البلاد لذلك يعني
قد يؤدي هذا الامر الى شرك كبير داخل
المجتمع لان المجتمع صار اصبح في مكان
ثاني مكان اخر متقدم على النظام يعني
الكاس الذي يريده النظام من المجتمع من
الصعب ان يتحقق لان المجتمع الايراني خاصه
الجيل المثقف والجيل الشبابي قطع اشواط
طويله بعيدا عن النظام في تحقيق اهدافه
وثقافته وكل همم ادواته الفكريه بعيدا عن
المؤسسه الرسميه للنظام وعن الفكر الذي
انتجته مؤسسه النظام
شرخا كما يرى همم سيد حسن قام انه سيكون
مرفوض من الاساس كما يقول البعض العوده
للوراء بمحاوله همم طرح فكره جديده لالغاء
مثلا مواد علميه لالغاء الفسف في التعليم
هل سيكون مقبول همم مع اخذ الاعتبار
الظروف التي تعيش ايران اليوم
لا انا براي سيعطي نتائج عكسيه وسيزيد من
زخم المظاهرات والاحتجاجات في الجامعات
كما تفعل السلطات في سائر المجالات بدل
تهدئه الاوضاع والرد على مطالب المحتاجين
يقومون بالقتل
وتتحول
مراسم تشييع القتلى الى احتجاجات جديده
وهكذا تستمر الاحتجاجات يعني خامن اي شخص
يعيش خارج الواقع منفصل عن المجتمع يعيش
خارج التاريخ هداك وسط اليوم وصفته شقيقته
التي همم
نشرت بانا وصافته بالخليفه المستبده الذي
لا يستمع للشعب ويريد ان ينتهج الخميني في
الثمانينات نهج القتل والاعدامات وعدم
الاستماع خامنه يعتقد انه همم لديه
ميليشات في الداخل وفي الخارج وسيستمر بهم
في بناء امبراطوريه الولي الفقير وان
الجامعات والاصوات التي تخرج في داخل
ايران مجرد يعني ناس
منحرفين كما يصف بالعوده الى بيان اخت
خامنه ايه هو الذي نشره همم ابنها من
فرنسا همم ولو يمكن توضيح هذه الجزء هي
لانه اتبعنا التصريحات منقوله او مترجمه
الى العربي فربما ليست هناك دقه كبيره
اختك وكانها كذلك تلقي باللوم على الحرس
الثوري تقول بان همم لا تصله صوره كامله
همم الحرس الثوري والمحيطون بخامنئه يصلون
الصوره بطريقه مخلوطه فهو عليه ان يستمع
للشعب ما الذي ارادت قوله ان كانت قالت
هذا الكلام نعم ام لا نحن قرانا هكذا في
الترجمه وان عم ما الذي اراد قوله
لا هي قالت ان الحرس الثوري تحولوا الى
ميليشيات ماجوره قاتله بيد خامنه وقالت
انها هي بنفسها اوصلت له عده رسائل انما
يفعله ليس صحيحا ويجب ان يستمع لاصوات
الشعب لكنها قالت انه ينتج نهج الخميني ان
يستمر بالقلب دعت الحرس الثوري الى القاء
السلاح والاصطفاف مع الجماهير كما نعلم
يعني هي همم منذ البدايه لم تتلقى معامله
منذ وان زوجها عارض الحرب العراقيه
الايرانيه وعارضا النظام الشيخ علي مراد
خالي الذي كان يعرف الشيخ علي طهران وذهب
الى العراق واسس اذاعه فارسيه معارضه من
هناك همم لكن همم هذا يدل على ان المقربين
من يعلمون بنفسيته بعناده وبانهده يريد ان
يستمر بهذا النهج القمعي ولا يرى احد سواه
سيستمر بهذا الخطاب بمواجهه شعبيه
وكان كذلك يقول مراقبون هناك اعتراف من
خمينا على ان مرحله التطوير التي شهدتها
ايران بنسبيه هي مرحله نسبيه همم وكانه
هناك ندم عليها على كل الناس سيبقى
الموضوع للمتابعه ربما نناقش هذه النقطه
لاحقا من بيروت الكتب الصحفي حسن فحص من
الرياض البحث في شان الايراني صالح حميد
شكرا جزيلا لكما السلام عليكم